اي ينضم الينا من مطار رونالد ريجين حسين
الطود مراسل العربيه اهلا بك حسين
لنبحث اولا بموضوع السفر لانه تعطيل
المطارات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في كريسماس في عيد الميلاد شيء مهم جدا هل
ما زالت هذه الازمه العاصفه لا زالت تعطل
حركه السفر
المطارات التي تتاثر بها كثيرا هي
المطارات الكبيره مثل مطار اتلانتا او
مطار سان فرانسيسكو او مطار شيكاغو وخاصه
الرحلات التي تتجه نحو
الولايات الشماليه التي ضربتها العاصفه
لاسيما المحيطه او التي تضم منطقه
البحيرات التي تلقت القوه الكبرى من هذا
الانفجار الكبير القطبي الكبير الذي وصلنا
نحن هنا همم فرجينيا وفي ميرندا ااه
تاثيره في الحقيقه ولكن اليوم كان هناك
تحسن بالنسبه لاعاده الجدول الرحلات هناك
وتاخير لبعض الرحلات لدي بعض الارقام
تاخير نحو ثلاثه الاف 1650 رحله والغاء
1937 رحله بينما كان يوم الجمعه كان هناك
الغاء مقارنه همم ثلاثه همم الغاء ثلاثه
الاف 1480 رحله هنا في مطار ايه رونالدو
المحامي للعاصمه
من 500 رحله تم الغائها وتاجيلها يوم
الجمعه يوم الذروه الذي يسبق ليله عيد
الميلاد المجيد الان نتحدث عن بعض الرحلات
التي ايضا الغيت بالنسبه للرحلات المتوجهه
نحو الشمال لكن كانت المفارقه ان ااه
سالنا احد العاملين هنا واحد المسؤولين
قال لنا انه هناك رحله تم الغاءها تتجه
نحو الجنوب نحو فلوريدات هذا امر غريب
لانه فلوريدا صحيح فيها موجه برد قارس
ولكن لا يوجد عصير ولا ثلوج همم
كما ذكرنا تفضل
يعني المشهد من خلفك هو في مطار رونلد
ريجن لا اعتقد ان
المشهد ستاثر كثير لانه حركه السفر ب25
يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا تكون بزخامه 24
و23 اذا ممكن للكاميرا ان تصلي الضوء من
حول من حولك يعني او من خلفك
ستتحرك بالكاميرا كما قلت ريما اليوم لم
يكن هناك ضغط كبير لان كما قلنا همم معظم
الضغط كان في يومين الثالث والعشرين
والرابع والعشرين من ليله عيد الميلاد
تحديدا حيث كانت العاصفه قويه جدا همم
ممكن نصور شويه كاميرته عم بتهز اكثر ما
لازم همم
ويحاول ان يساعدني
توجه قليلا الى الامام
طيب فيما انت تتحدث ونرى مشاهد المسافرين
يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا تكون كبيره ولكن
هناك الغاءت الفتني حسين انه اتصلت ببعض
الاصدقاء من ميامي من بعض الوقت حتى ما
يامن لاعاده تقسم دبي مثلا في برد ولابسين
كنزات همم اخبرني عن الولايات التي تاثرت
بالفعل يعني نستطيع ان نقول ريما الولايات
التي نجت من هذا الانفجار القطبي من
الثلوج تاثرت برياحها العاتيه في الحقيقه
يعني ان يتم تح- ااه توجيه تحضيرات الى
سكان فلوريدا المعروفه بانها ولايه دافئه
هذا امر غريب ومستغرب همم بسبب هذه
البروده القارصه ايضا ادت الى ضغط كبير
على شبكات الكهرباء ومحطات تبيض الكهرباء
بسبب همم استخدام المواطنين في هذه
الولايات غير المعتدين في الحقيقه على هذه
الموجه البارده همم ادوات التدفئه
والتسخير ما ادى الى وجود ضغط على محطات
التوليد الكهرباء وايضا انقطاع الكهرباء
عن عدد كبير من الناس همم الان في هنا في
الولايات المتحده يوجد بحسب احصاءات رسميه
175,000 منزل يعانون من انقطاع الكهرباء
طبعا كان العدد اكبر يوم الجمعه حيث كان
هناك مليون و500,000 منزل عانوا من انقطاع
الكهرباء
قلنا العاصفه هدات اا قليلا همم بتاثيرها
هذا قليلا البارحه كانت درجات الحراره هنا
في همم شمال فيرجينيا وفي ميرلاند نحو 16
تحت الصفر اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اثنين تحت
الصفر كما قلت انا الان في هنا في المطار
الحركه اليوم شبه عاديه هناك تاخيرات و
تاجيل ولكن نحن حسب ما قيل لنا هذا
التاجيل تاجيل طبيعي بعضها خاصه الرحلات
المتوجهه نحو الشمال هي تم تاجيله همم
بسبب العاصفه التي تضرب همم ولايه شمال
ولا سينما منطقه همم غرب همم همم ولايه
غرب همم نيويورك وتحديدا مطري جون
افكانيدي ولاغوارديا في هذه الولايه همم
هناك كل شيء مغلق الثلوج تغطي همم المدرج
ولكن بشكل عام في الولايات الباقيه هناك
برد ولكن الرحلات عادت كما كانت المسافرين
العرب
في ليله راس السنه شكرا لك من مطار
حسين الطود مراسل العربيه